let's move on to Ed Sharon who could
lose Millions it's day four of his
copyright infringement trial here is the
latest
[Music]
Ed took the sand for a third day and
made this shocking pledge he will quit
his music career if he loses because
it's such an insult to be accused of
theft
[Music]
with 100 million dollars at stake Ed is
accused of ripping off Marvin Gaye's
song Let's Get It On for his hit
thinking out loud
[Music]
trial is set to wrap up tomorrow then on
Wednesday the 32 year old's emotionally
charged documentary the sum of it all
streams on Disney plus Harry's house it
was really bad in the four-part series
Ed's wife Cherry Seaborn speaks out for
the first time since her cancer
diagnosis last year this beauty when
it's Bleak we had the diagnosis of the
tumor and the day after Ed's went down
into the basement and wrote seven songs
in like what four hours maybe it was
yeah and it's been nearly five months
since dancer and choreographer Steven
twitch boss's private depression battle
led to his tragic suicide
which did not have a will and a Los
Angeles judge just granted his wife
Allison holker half of his estate and
future earnings it speculated the other
half could go to their three kids I hope
that we can remember
the feeling that he gave us over the
weekend Allison focused on creating
feelings of Joy she shared these
precious photos of their two youngest
children Maddox and Zaya at Universal
Studios captioning them quote beautiful
memories being created
foreign